worked example 8 says consider the
probability density function P where and
you can read this stuff here P of x
equals well I just rubbed it off
whatever 20 they give you a domain P of
x equals zero otherwise and then they
say okay a and B find expected value
we're going to find this guy
okay so that's revision from yesterday
and then Part B we're then gonna move on
to this we're gonna try and find that
variance okay so let's um let's rehearse
this because you need the expected value
can you see there the MU here and the
Museu you need expected value to find
out variance so let's go ahead and do
this so Part A okay this is the function
P of x equals 1 over 20 and it's defined
between 25 and 45 yeah 25 and 45 okay no
no this is still reasonably fresh in our
minds so thankfully we've got it written
here right here's our formula for
finding an expected value so let's go
ahead and work out what it is expected
value equals I'm gonna integrate across
my entire domain so that's 25 to 45
that's what was defined for us and then
I'm gonna go put an extra X in and then
multiplied by the function right now
here's the function 1 over 20 when I
multiply that guy by an extra X it just
becomes x over 20 okay that's not too
bad right I can handle this
so the primitive of X on xx is x squared
on 40 very good and then maybe you're
already getting to your calculator what
we're going to do is we're going to
substitute in our upper and lower
boundaries while you guys are doing that
I'm gonna factor out that 40 because I'm
lazy and don't want to evaluate it twice
in my calculator here comes the upper
boundary here comes the lower boundary
and then you're gonna get some number
out of this okay now what I want you to
do just to be really sneaky right I
don't want you to hit equals on your
calculator yet go ahead and punch in all
the numbers but before you hit equals I
just wonder if you can think about like
can we make a prediction about what the
answer should be before we get there cuz
I had a message sure who always taught
me always guess always guess
before you get an answer because either
you'll be writing you'll be like yes on
the bond right or you'll be wrong and
you learn something okay so think about
this have a look at your probability
density function we even just refer to
this about five minutes ago what kind of
probability density function is this
it's uniform very good like it's one it
it's the exact number I chose before
it's one over twenty all the way every
outcome 25 26 27 and a half everything
in my domain is equally likely
now remember expected value is the same
as the mean right so if all the values
have the same likelihood and you're
allowed to go between 25 and 45 where do
you expect the mean to be in your
distribution it should be right smack
bang in the middle at 35 right go ahead
and hit equals and tell me it's 35 right
yeah I see I told you you're like I feel
awesome okay any of you have something
different that's fine you're like oh
okay now I see why okay all right so
stay with me you twelve mmm puppy we've
got our mean we've got our expected
value now we're going to use that guy to
find out variance now before we write
down anything we have to make a decision
which one of these are we going to use
now remember I told you this is the
specific example so my function is nice
and easy
I can go via the hard way because what
I've got here even though it's um it's
the hard method because the probability
density function going into it's not
that bad I can use it okay so let's have
a go I'm going to do this top line for
this particular situation okay so I'm
gonna write down variance equals here
comes my integral where am i integrating
from 25 to 45 it's the whole domain 25
to 45 okay then here comes the
difference from the mean it's whatever
scores you have take away whatever we
just worked out the mean was which was
35 that thing gets squared we're
squaring it because we're interested in
the in the magnitude not which way it's
facing okay and then I have to multiply
by 1 over 20 because that's the
probability density
function 1 over 20 DX okay now from here
like I said before you like oh now I'm
in calculus mode okay so you could
probably take over from here but just
for the sake of time let's have a god
this together okay the one over 20 just
a constant coefficient so I'm going to
chuck it out the front that leaves you
with X minus 35 or squared now if you
wanted you could expand it and then you
could integrate term by term but you
don't need to look at it we have
knowledge they can integrate directly
from this form what can we do yeah sure
maybe we can do reverse chain rule here
right we can look at this inside
derivative right you're like oh inside
derivative it's just 1 so I'm gonna
divide by 1 nothing happens right I do
with the outside it's a squared thing so
the squared is going to turn into a 3
and then you have to divide by your new
power right for what it's worth I also
divided by the inside derivative but
doesn't change anything so it's that
okay and then I go from 25 to 45 okay
now this point here I mean I'm also
going to factorize that 3 out so I'll
have 1 over 60 in fact I'll write this
down but it's sort of just calculator
work from here when I was 60 what am I
gonna get in here 45 takeaway 35 last I
checked that was 10 25 takeaway 35
that's going to be negative 2 right
ten cubes a thousand negative ten cute
is negative thousand so thousand plus a
thousand that's two thousand tell me if
you get two thousand on sixty which is
two hundred on six which is 100 on three
so your calculator telling you what's at
33 and a third 33 or third someone's
calculator please make me feel better
okay which part you can do these here I
did a lot of stuff in my head I'll grant
you that what was I doing okay a few a
few things happened at once so first
thing that happened was the 3 inner 20
yes ok then the next thing that happened
was I started to put in my 45 and my 25
in there so this guy's 45 take away 35
yep yeah it came out the phone okay did
it did I get there 33 or third someone
please make me feel better
Hydra over 3 which is 33 with it okay
fantastic oh yeah I meant to have a
square bracket there as well
I'll make it feel slightly less lonely
house that said that okay all right
so this is a 33 and a third that's our
variance now the question you can see on
the waste example the question doesn't
ask this but I kind of feel your brain
should always go in this direction
anytime you get asked the question like
this if you've got variance standard
deviation is just the square root of
that so just go ahead just for the sake
of interest right go to your calculator
it's square root and so what do you get
what do you get square root of this this
is variance right so this is Sigma
square five point seven seven three five
dot
I assume okay so if you wanted to know
what the standard deviation is it's that
okay